what's going on guys this is rob and
it's been a minute since i've shown all
of you my beautiful face but we're gonna
react to the thor love and thunder
trailer the official trailer trailer two
let's get into it y'all
[Music]
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god i love the coordination
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god
and after all that
he reclaimed his title oh
as the one and only four
god i love the way james foster looks
jay
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
god she looks amazing what's your family
three four years eight years seven
months and six days give or take
oh olympus sensing
[Music]
you're
feelings
the only ones
[Applause]
oh
so this is my vow
oh god
oh my god thor looks amazing
i just wanna say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
it's just my first bag
[Music]
you never forget you're first
[Music]
i'm not like the other gods that kill
because i have something worth fighting
for wow
i love the way he looks
oh my god
let's see who you are and take off your
disguise
and flick
oh oh you flick two
should we help them eventually grape
you flick too hard dammit
i love that
gory looks amazing okay uh
i'm gonna we're gonna put this reaction
video together we're gonna get this
uploaded and then um
yeah
we're gonna do a breakdown because
we need to talk about gore